right good afternoon everyone welcome to
this meeting of cabinet's so first item
on the agenda is apologies for absence
we do we have apologies from councillors
Pemberton and Cargill thank you
moving on to the minutes and we have two
bills
- sorry disclosures of interest
now I can move on to minutes minutes we
have to lots of minutes of meetings held
on the 15th of July and 9th September
thank you
in that case I will sign the minutes
after the meeting so moving on to agenda
item for the council planet 2019
this into this f1 actually looks the
five specific priorities
of national and international stages
which is important for enhancing the
quality of structure by maven district
of the place of an inclusive economy
Financial Planning so those I think to
the highlights there is an awful lot of
data contained in the back and with that
is that are there any comments any
discussion any debate members of
cabinets councillor Perry thank you
leader I just wanted to say that having
worked in a professional capacity for
nearly 30 years working with people
developing business strategies and that
sort of thing I felt that the
consultancy that was selected provided a
really positive insight into
facilitating meetings and I felt that
having done this sort of thing with the
likes of Ernst and Young and other
leading professional firms I felt the
whole approach we were on a par with
having worked with sort of global
companies so if I could just add
particular thanks to the senior
management team for identifying very
good and very helpful consultancy to
take us through the process
thank you for your kind comments
councillor Perry I think I would endorse
everything you said it was an
exceedingly good process and I thought
the consultants we had did an extremely
effective job councillor Barker I would
endorse about the job that was done
unfortunately some of what was done has
not actually come out in the wash
finally on the leaflet and I am finding
it hard to find words that I've actually
used in this and I just think that
perhaps if we could simplify the English
a bit which was something I did bang on
and on and on about the consultation
stage I'll just give you one example of
something under communities that I think
is clean - sorry doesn't look the same
as the one I had notes people sorry i
I've got to say that I don't think I'm
putting residents and community center
stage by saying that I'll ensure that
residents are confident the Council will
convene focused and timely discussions
on issues of concern to them that's a
bit it could do with plain English is
what I'm actually saying can we possibly
think about that because this isn't this
is still not absolutely there I know I'm
possibly being very difficult but I
don't like it
mr. book okay to ask you to do today is
to recommend to council the approval of
the council plan we can absolutely look
at the leaflet which is a work in
progress is to give you a feeling as may
be out at the moment but the actual crux
of it is under appendix what about that
that's the council plan the leaflet is
the company it's a supported document
but we have got some latitude on
as long as we have some latitude and it
can be fiddled with I'm perfect Fred to
turn some of it into plain English
myself fine I think that what we've
actually heard from mr. Buckland means
we still have time to play with the
leaflet so Junod apart from saying thank
you very much for making sure that
climate change of the consultants are
why however was a high priority just
wonder whether I could pick up on one
very very small thing which is on page
15 you talk about ambitions to ensure
that the district benefits from Coventry
City of Culture I wonder whether you
could take up with the appropriate
authorities maybe through the your
partnership working with Coventry I've
only just recently come across the fact
that there are grants available to
support action within this district as a
result of the Coventry City of Culture
provider do you have the right postcode
and if you have a CV postcode you can
get a grant if you are like Oscar a be
49 postcode you can't get a grant sir
perhaps you know if we are benefiting
the whole district as a result of
Coventry City of Culture could we please
take that up and say look it shouldn't
make a difference about having a
postcode I think you make a very valid
point councillors unit I think that is
something we will take up I think it's
also worth just saying that mr. Buckland
and I have had a meeting with the people
at the Coventry City of Culture and they
did issue is that they wanted to involve
our district as much as possible so
that's a relationship we will continue
and hope to build further councillor
Richards thank Jeff so from nowhere to
seat this is from an RFC perspective
there was a jump as we obviously saw
this paper last week RSC are our OSC
meeting and there was a general sense of
I get surprised in disappointment that
in the interest of pre decision scrutiny
this hadn't
come through our committee beforehand
however that said there was also some
support to the fact that and recognition
of the fact that all councils have been
afforded the opportunity to be part of
that consultation process there's no
particular issue with the work
it's the pre decision scrutiny which we
talked about before would have been
helpful thank you
Thank You councillor Richards I think I
would say that the involvement of all
councillors and a lot of residents and
this has been extremely good councillor
Harvey Thank You mr. chair and I sort of
like to echo canceller Perry's words I
could say something about the consultant
but it would only be repetitious but my
point is that the whole process enabled
councillors and officers to spend a
significant amount of time together and
I think in the life of the new council I
thought that was extremely helpful
because that enabled us to knock some
corners off and ticket to understand
each other's motivations and strengths
and weaknesses in a way which had we not
done it we've taken a lot longer so it
almost suggests that every time there is
a change of host election an election
it's almost de rigueur this is the sort
of exercise that ought to be undertaken
because of the the informal information
and understanding it generates I thought
was extremely helpful I think I would
fully endorse your comments councillor
Harvey and I have to say that I thought
one of the things the process did do as
you've said is he actually made there
were working relationship between
offices and cabinet much better so with
that the recommendation to Council on
page 9 subject to the fact that the
leaflet can be tweaked the vision for
stratford-on-avon District Council 2030
together with the council plan 2019 23
sure that appendix won't be approved
we all agree man please cabinet thank
you very much
okay there is a blue paper or that
should accompany this if people want to
talk about the blue paper which does not
contain I think anything that
significantly changes this paper then
we'll have to go into exempt session and
remove members of the public so this is
a paper on the senior management
structure that has been through
employment and appointments committee
and from what I would say is that we had
a very thorough debate and discussion at
employment and appointments committee
with also in putting these papers
together taken a significant amount of
advice from the West Midlands employers
Association and if one actually looks at
the what we have decided how what we are
putting out to consultation is proposed
to change the senior management
structure the council and to agree to
commence formal consultation we've said
that the dual leadership team we believe
needs replacing with a chief executive
and a deputy chief executive what we're
also saying is that given the increased
complexity and increased demands on the
senior management team and we really are
finding at the moment that the bandwidth
in capacity given the context is
stretched so we will we are hoping
subject to council agreement to appoint
one extra head of service this will give
us far more resilience and far more
cover and in the current climate
is really important so the consultation
has commenced so what we are
recommending is that option two of the
new senior management structure is put
to council and cabinet also recommends
to Council that they approve the
additional budget required to achieve
this we have to do that so we get all
the ducks in a line before we go to
recruitment so with that cabinet
any questions any discussion any debate
I'll take that as a no so in that case
the recommendation on page one can I
have your approval please thank you
members of cabinet
right moving on
material recycling facility oh sorry
my apologies yes given there is a blue
paper on the material recycling facility
now given that I would imagine it that
in the discussion and debate on the
material recycling facility that there
will be indeed to refer to that blue
paper I'm going to take the all the
discussion on the material recycling
facility at the end because I think that
- given it is a blue paper then the
public will be excluded from that part
of the debate so moving on place
portfolio debate delivering local needs
local choice rural housing on page 49
this is a routine report that comes to
cabinet every year we consider the
progress on the schemes we have as an
aim in our housing strategy to support
communities including increase in the
supply in choice of good quality
affordable homes for loop local people
we fund a rural housing enabler and the
reason why we have that is pretty
obvious when you look at our district
which is a widely dispersed pattern of
rural settlements it's worth commenting
of that since 2005 6 296 new rural homes
have been built and the rural housing
enabler who I have to say does an
excellent job he's currently working
actively with 39 communities
this could result up to 321 law ohms so
as I say progress since July 2018 has
been good and completed local need
housing schemes are popular with the
local communities built in response to
identified needs and the desire to
reflect what is important to local
people so with that as I said this is a
routine report that comes every year and
ensures that we keep an eye on what is
going on
councillor JUnit not necessarily for
here but I wonder whether at some point
I could have perhaps have some
information as to why community land
Trust's are not being taken up as an
idea it's again not for you but on the
from the paperwork I wonder whether you
could endorse and make sure that the
nine point three point one which is the
about making sure that there is an
energy efficient approach taken to
houses it is is made very strong because
keeping energy costs down actually
prevents fuel poverty which is one of
the things you're having to spend money
on at the moment more than happy to do
that councillor geo node and I wish you
well in delving further into community
land Trust's I have done it and believe
me it's interesting councillor kettle
thank you 39 communities are addressed
here I think from recollection they're
about 117 communities within stratford
district are we convinced that we're
reaching wide enough across the district
to ensure that where local need homes
might be required that we're getting
coverage across districts rather than
a proportion of the district I think in
reality the answer to that councilor
kettle is yes because although they're
being actively working with 39
communities there has been engagement
with more I think what the issue
actually is communities have to engage
and one cannot actually force them to
but from the discussions we've had
previously I think the local housing
needs the manager of this is doing
everything they can to make sure as many
communities as possible are involved we
can do as well the council should be
doing to encourage who aren't engaging
in able to get into some of those
settlements which aren't listed is a
very good comment councilor careful and
I think that he's something that we will
take up with the rural housing enabler
councillor Perry sorry sorry yeah mr.
chairman I just wanted to add that in
fact wearing my ward members role in
view of all the site allocations
proposals coming forward on small
villages in particular local service
villages have been actually encouraging
the parish councillors to update their
local housing needs survey and so in
fact I think they're going to be a few
few more that we can add to this list
but certainly highlighting that whilst
the site allocations plan is for reserve
sites is very important that local
communities update their housing needs
survey so that there are local needs
housing
is up to date in the event that any of
these reserved sites came forward I
would agree with that counselor Perry I
think it also just pick up that in
response to councilor kettle on page 51
that a 60 Green Communities where
progress is being made that's about half
the parishes in the district which i
think is a good result so with that
members of cabinet the recommendations
on page 49 is everyone happy with those
Thank You members of cabinet review of
garden waste processing options a
council sent in I believe Thank You mr.
chairman and the council is required to
maintain a balance medium term financial
plan and as a result of significant
reductions in funding central government
funding the council is having to
investigate ways of closing the budget
deficit which is currently forecast for
features one of the options that we've
been considered is the introduction of a
charge for the garden waste services the
service is a discretionary service it's
not statutory and it's not used by all
the residents of the district the report
before you this afternoon suggests that
public and stakeholder consultation
which should be carried out on a
proposal to introduce a charge for the
garden waste service following that
consultation a further report will be
presented to cabinet in December so that
an informed decision about whether or
not to introduce a charge for the
service
thank you the details that even proposal
in the body of the report and it's
recommended before we move on to that do
you just want to outline the financial
position of the council going forward
please George yeah thank you Vega I
think members will be aware of the
medium term financial plan that was
approved in February last year by the
council and in that it was projecting
over the life of the plan that there'd
be a deficit of some three million
pounds by by the end an annual deficit
and that is what this project is trying
to start to address thank you
counts cabinet and even councillor Perry
thank you I would just like to thank my
colleague opposite Ian Shenton for
producing such a thorough report and I
was particularly interested to see there
are so many other councils operating
this particular service as someone who
is very keen to promote climate change
of course the best thing would be of all
would be that everybody composted at
home anyway and you know I would like to
hope that I mean obviously depends on
the consultation process but hopefully
such an initiative would actually
encourage a number of homeowners to
compost at home anyway which would be
which would be a great improvement so
but I thought it was excellently put out
and a lot of
Meishan so thank you for that helpful
information sorry counselor Junod I'd
like to have a couple more things
actually looked at number one is the
government in its own way strategy is
looking at both whether garden waste
should be collected or whether there
should be a charge for it or not and
they're also looking at food waste
collections it's true that if they if
they decide that they may very well be a
fun debate about from government but we
can't always you can't always depend on
that you may find that you've got a
directive and and you have to do it so
I'm just raising that as a question
secondly there is going there's going to
be a downside for the District Council
in the your recycling targets because if
you did remove green waste your
recycling target is going to be even on
an optimistic forty percent to take up
it's going to drop from number ten to
number 91 in the targets because it
clearly shows up that we're not doing
enough on dry recyclates and at the
moment six percent of food waste
actually goes into your green waste it
is keeping it out of the black bins it's
not a lot but it is keeping her to the
black bins which currently goes to an
incinerator energy from waste facilities
so you know it's look I'd like to take
you to have a look at the carbon
footprint of the options because my
worry is for example if there is a
charge and just say an imaginary village
and it's got ten people in that village
and at the moment all of them pay all of
them have green waste collected but only
one of them Cho chooses to take up the
charge the lorry will still have to go
there for that one so is it really
reducing the carbon footprint overall so
I'd like you to kind of look in at those
ones look at the government strategy
consider whether or not we are whether
they are you are being premature on that
one
but from the environmental point of view
the best option to respond the
consideration with respect to those
circumstances it's quite obvious to the
consultation period is going to run on
for some time in this and there's no
definitive view on this at the moment as
far as charging for green waste is
concerned again the the government have
given an indication they may have to
rethink their views on that as so many
kind of source of responded that they
want to charge or are charging we see 65
to 70% of all councils charging and
obviously that funding is removed it has
to come from somewhere else so I think
that they'd agreed chances are getting a
response from government quickly
the final response I get the feeling you
mind just play instructors and forwards
on the dress dry recyclers issue the
right six percent of food waste but in
the grave in itself where we can pull
back this recycling rate in the grave in
itself up to thirty four percent thirty
five percent of that is actually either
recyclable or compostable so it's quite
obvious that there is an education piece
here in trying to remove items out of
the grave in and get it into the moving
or the green bin so we can affect our
recycling rate by being more proactive
and maybe be innovative in the ways that
we approach the education piece so I
actually think whilst they're moving
fall back and nobody's saying they won't
we can address that going forward and we
have to be we have to do this through a
combination of education and enforcement
in the most successful countries
recycling the government's tend to
legislate very heavily and set targets
for local authorities which if they fail
to meet them they are subject is to be a
penalty there's obviously a driver there
to meet the to meet the targets that
isn't the case in this country so we
have to do it ourselves and educate so
we can we can bring that recycle rate
back up we do need to do educate the
carbon footprint I take your point on
that that if there's only one in a
village that's not particularly if you
like carbon friendly but this proposal
is more about financial with sort of
carbon benefits on the side we don't
have to address that maybe as we go
along to see what we can do about that
but I take it on board
Thank You counselor Shenton I believe in
other councils that have done this that
actually the take-up of paying the
charge for having the green wares
collected who's been fairly high anyway
and accelerate over two years and so we
will see that steadily naturally but
that would be to ignore all the
education Thank You Kelsey Richards
thank you very much chair and so once
again from our perspective we were
really pleased to have councillors
Jensen come to our meeting last week he
very constantly in Abele answered all
the questions that our members had so
we're very thankful for that there were
three points that came out of that
you've already actually covered one but
I'll bring it up again in a second the
first was that there was a request that
more detail was provided on the
alternatives that were considered in the
lead-up to coming to this the conclusion
of one should consider charging and we
didn't really see much of that within
the report that could be part of a
preamble of the consultation or within
the consultation just some information
particularly the public so they
understand how we've got the decision we
have examples included of having the
first been for free as they do in North
workshop potentially suspending or
reducing the service over the winter
months when there's less gonna be less
garden waste the second was that if the
charge of all green waste were to be
introduced OSC would request that
consideration is given to the cost
benefits being used for the wider
environmental initiatives such as the
district became carbon neutral by 2030
and the final one is about the common
strategy and the education particularly
around composting and the benefits of
home composting and home recycling
rather than dumping straight into a
green or graben if you wish to respond
the council Shenton
history's go okay so number three points
taken 21 on the alternatives the and
close being free we have we have look at
that we but we can we continue to have a
look at it on the I think nothing is set
in stone yet so on the back of that
consultation then we'll review it again
the as far as the cost benefits being
used if you like for punitive carbon
footprints and uses I remember the
conversation and I think the
conversation did edge along the lines of
we wouldn't want the council to be tied
at this stage on but we take again take
that on board and because we need first
of all we need to sort that immediate
and financially and status by that and
then we can look and as far as the
current strategy okay thank you can
solution turn
so without if there's no more debate the
recommendations on page 67 that the
introduction of the proposed chargeable
garden where services out landings drop
report we approved for public and
stakeholder consultation and that the
outcome of the public and stakeholder
consultation is presented to cabinet in
December for further consideration can I
have your approval please cabinet great
Thank You members of cabinet so moving
on rural and urban capital improvements
grant scheme I believe this is you
council about it is
[Applause]
this runs from page 85 through 209 and
includes a copy of the Social Inclusion
statement from which you couldn't see
what the priorities are that have been
targeted on page 108 the thematic and
geographic and the they also relates to
if you'll pardon me just anything to
this the IMD scores for the lowers super
output areas the new ones have come out
I think today I saw them for at least in
the last few days if there's a newer set
but I can tell you that that lot on page
106 sadly because there's not that much
movement although there is some movement
within the list I didn't bring the
precise figures with me but going back
to the page 108 and those are the
protease protein one is education
employment and training and increasing
income and reducing debt in these areas
combating social isolation conducting
rural isolation supporting older people
particularly empowering communities and
improving well mental well-being so
quite a lot on geographically and
personally speaking for those people I
would also part of the information also
that was used the evidence that this was
based on refers to the Warwick scheme
which
if that starts on page 93 and I just
want to make the point that there is a
difference between the Warwick scheme
and what we can do in the ORAC District
Council ring-fenced its new homes bonus
for this to boost their reserves and we
have no such pot you've also heard that
the pot is emptier than we would like it
to be anyway
per the medium term financial plan there
are other grants available page 19 1
you'll see those the sort of grants that
are available for people and I have also
as a local councillor local district
councillor for this place but also as a
county councillor I suggest potential
additions to the local precept which I'm
finding more and more parish councils
are accepting because they accept the
need for making particular progress in
their own communities and their
communities except that they are having
to do more for themselves which of
course is part of what the social
inclusion statement is trying to
encourage we only know one year of the
settlement so we are living in difficult
times and finally I'd like to give you
an example of a community that did it
for itself in councillor Wally Huggins
patch in fact Charrington and Staunton
and certainly under brailles raised
stupid amounts of money over a million
pounds and National Lottery funding
forces things to build an absolutely
superb village hall so they funded a
capital project like that and it wasn't
out of deep pockets because again when
you look at the list of that I pointed
you to earlier brailles is one of the
areas with whether it's in the area of
deprivation it doesn't think it appears
on this one but it's higher up long
companies but it is higher up
in the on the IMD schools this year so
whilst I commend the wish to provide
money I don't think now is the time for
capital to be applied like this in
parishes there is section 106 money and
some there is SIL in some and if you're
lucky enough to live in the green button
and not to be affected then hooray so
the option that I would propose the
cabinet on page 87 is 4.1 cabinet does
not support the developers of rural
urban urban Capital Improvement Grants
Scheme
Thank You chairman it was just really a
point as a part of the report if I may
with regards to the map it seems to
happen
sorry it's page page full of the indices
of yes page 105 and it happens a lot
whether it's the system but as wells
born is a main rural center and does
feature in the top 10 could we possibly
have wells forum included as a point of
reference on the map it is on there in
the middle it doesn't show up so well
cause it's black and white but it is
smack-bang by Stratford it could
actually be a much bigger place a new
town stratford-upon-avon wells born it's
in the wrong place
yes we'll move the tweet dot because we
have it in the right place you better
not report me to the Royal Geographical
Society very young children of 11 to 13
there is literally nothing for them to
do in these villages if you go into the
bigger the picket areas like ships and
there are things that they can do but
very much so in these pockets of rural
isolation I was not surprised excited
when I read this proposal thinking I
felt was just a little bit of money that
we could help our communities with that
will be a fantastic thing I think and
could make a big difference to some of
our more isolated coming
and particularly some older people and
younger people in in those areas
councillor Junod so councillor Barker
sorry if we had all the money in the
world and I had a magic monetary here
it'd be fine
I haven't the this is also about capital
funding and I'm fairly familiar with the
same patch I know exactly what you're
talking about but to be honest in the
community of 90 for instance they've
already got a village hall you know the
one I'm referring to but there are in a
lot of those places there's the capital
they just aren't the people to help and
so one of the reasons for that the
social isolation you know that the
statement says what it does is that
we're actually trying to empower people
more so that this capital this game
would have nothing to do with say the
you bus which we've already saved and
put a lot more money into perhaps than
anyone might have thought we were going
to so that's the tack that I want us to
take I don't actually want us to put any
more money into bricks and mortar at
this stage I want to spend what money
we've got from this on enabling people
okay thank you very unsympathetic to
this proposal in theory but I'm
conscious of the practicalities of lack
of cash to put behind it what it will
point to however is I was at a meeting
of ships in Town Council last month and
one of the items for debate was whether
she'd shift a hundred thousand pounds
from one account to another account and
to earn an extra bit of interest I am
aware for instance that Stratford town
council I believe has reserves of
something of the order of half million
pounds now it's not for me to say to
parish councils what reserve policy they
should have and I'm sure they have
thought through why they've got reserves
and why they're holding them for what
purpose however I would not be surprised
if 109 parish councils in the district
were to have a serious look that there
is enough policy on policies whether
there isn't the capacity to generate
some funds to support this sort of
activity from their own resources
council barker councillor Harvey and I
had a conversation about this last
Thursday and I'm absolutely in agreement
I can tell you that from my reading of
the ship Stern Town Council they got 500
grand in reserves as well it's not just
Stratford now they're the big ones but I
have I I haven't gone into it but I know
councillor Harvey is going to there is
money sloshing around to the people just
that the smaller councils are sitting on
and not using and that is their council
taxpayers money and so all those of us
who sit on parish councils where we
maybe have seen the books I would just
ask that very gently we try and probe
and see whether they don't want to put
some of their money where their mouth is
councillor Barker
councillor JUnit this as I understand it
because this was put forward before I
became came back on to the council but
as I understand it this was not just for
helping parish councils but was for
not-for-profit community organisations
who often don't have the kind of money
you're talking about there is an option
on here that four point four which is
that you could have this as two up the
requirement to install carbon reduction
measures as part of a grant funded
scheme and you could use it very much
more for community organizations some of
whom are struggling quite quite have
quite a struggle to raise any funds at
all and I speak as somebody that does
share several community organizations
that are not-for-profit you've just been
talking about greenways charge where
you're talking about a million pounds
bringing in I know that the councillors
I've got problems a head-on deficit but
if you are serious about reducing the
carbon footprint across the district
some of these organizations do need to
know or do need to have some recourse to
funds to help them do it how how you
could do that is for you to work out but
I'm just saying that it's not all about
parish council projects transfer Barker
forgive me and I did not mention the
other community organizations I did
refer I referred to one I'm particularly
familiar with where they raised a lot
from the National Lottery and that
wasn't the parish councils what I am
saying and I think you we have to agree
is that there is money sloshing about
out there and when when things are so
tight I think that that could be the
first reports I know for instance in my
own patch that there are always there's
always the potential for grant
applications and as you and I both know
running tiny organisations often it
doesn't
that much money so I'm reasonably
encouraged that with good work from
local councilors and encouragement to
our parishes and to the community
organizations with which we're linked
and helping them fit in forms from time
to time as I certainly do that we will
make the best of what is a very
difficult situation councillor Richard
thank you Jeff um I guess I'm coming out
with two heads on partly it was
obviously myself that along with City
Council Orton who put this to council
some time ago
and also from an oversea perspective so
I thought if I can go from my
perspective first and then move to our
Savior than me
so I mean naturally I'm disappointed
with the direction in which is going
although I do recognize what has been
said by members and the financial
pressures that that are on the council
on the comment was made about the
Greenbelt parishes that was we don't
have to suffer any development there is
still some development in there I think
that one of the purposes of one of the
thought processes behind this is that
those Greenbelt parishes don't get the
opportunity to gain any SIL benefit so
as almost their support to those
parishes
I just wanted to make that point what I
would say again from a personal
perspective is I'd like to thank the
council the cabinet and the Oviatt
scrutiny officers for the time and
effort they put into reviewing this I do
think it has been given at a fair
hearing and I do think it has gone
through due process so I just I do want
that put on record if if I may from the
overview discreetly perspective of we've
also had a detailed look at this and
discussed it one of the reasons why I
think why it was so unanimously
supported by the the scrutiny committee
is that there was a general feeling that
the constraints put in the supporting
documents which essentially confined the
type of grants that one could get would
limit the amount of money that's been
that's being spent
I guess as I said I guess that's why
that was put through and also that we
we recognize the existing budget
pressures that you have that we as a
council have which is why there was that
the line to suggest a maximum cap of two
hundred thousand pounds in any given
year I just wanted to make those points
again I guess from an overview screen
family and perspective we are where we
are it has been given due process do you
wait to your consideration and I think
we're we're happy with that so thank you
Thank You councillor Richards so the
proposal is that of the options
available to cabinet cabinet does not
support the development of a ruler and
an urban capital improvements grand
scheme can I have your agreement to that
recommendation members of cabinet thank
you members of cabinet
so moving on issues arising from
overview and scrutiny committee interim
recommendations from the climate
emergency task and finish group that
councillor Richards our councillor Junod
don't mind I think you've also now had
your copies of the recommendations that
we've put and the group has met on a
number of occasions now more recently
we've invited public and private bodies
to come and give us evidence from their
perspective as to what we shouldn't
shouldn't be doing in relation to the
climate emergency that has been declared
in the interests of expediency we are
seeking to put forward interim
recommendations ahead of a final report
that will be published in January and
those recommendations you all have
copies off they are as read I won't read
them out of item but I'm happy for us to
discuss and answer any questions that
you might have
any comments any questions any
discussion members of cabinet a Harvey
and this may be a tangential point of
interest
somewhere along the line have had
correspondence with somebody from from
the council who referred to what I
thought was a very useful document which
is the carbon management plan by
Cambridge and I have read it probably
not in as much detail as I ought serve
but the one thing that does take my eye
about the whole report is appendix B
Appendix A which lists out the various
initiatives that have been introduced
and the thing that takes my eye is that
it is quantified for each of the actions
each of the projects there is a carbon
footprint number this is the effect and
as the monetary effect though the only
thing and I know I've cancer Richards
knows that I've written to him with his
OSC hat on posing questions about what
some low-hanging fruit etc etc my my
request is the task and finish group to
the task and finish group but also to
the officers is the importance of
measurability that's that that is the
the big thing I am all in favor of this
council pursuing the objective of in
relation with the climate change policy
and to do it vigorously but I'm also in
favor of it doing it where it can make
the most impact and if we caught if we
don't have the information systems and
the data available
we won't know we'll be doing things on
on the basis of what we feel is good as
opposed to what we are likely to know is
like to be most effective so I just like
I don't expect somebody to say yes we've
got it all in place here and now but I
just like people to take note both
officers and and the task and finish
group that's
if you need I hope you share my my
feeling of the importance of data and
accuracy and making things quantifiable
when you're putting forward your
recommendations I think your points are
extremely well made councillor Harvey
councillor Richards and I think they are
as well and I absolutely agree Castle
hobby is quite right he has written and
requested some further information in
background on it specifically as he has
out led there outlined there I think
you've had a response now yeah and I
hope you're happy with it and I guess
the from from our personnel for
certainly from my perspective and ask
answered units come in and give her view
as well we're obviously looking to make
recommendations your final report which
will come in January will have all that
background information clearly we have
the benefit of a lot of that background
information where evidence gathering and
then bringing forward our
recommendations if it's more helpful to
you as a cabinet group to get all that
information and made perhaps as an
appendix to these recommendations I'm
sure we can do that but when we're not
we're not making them on a whim they are
fully supported by evidence that we have
so Janet and the Cambridge report was
one of the very first ones that we
managed to access and there are there
are others there Cambridge itself but
also leaves have done carbon footprint
quite a lot of data on their on their
carbon footprinting and of interest to
this council is that there are a couple
of organisations but notably the Tyndall
Climate Change chase Center which has
worked with the University to make
accessible to local authorities a tool
by which they can use it can calculate
their carbon footprint and break it down
for particular activities across not
only their own activities and their own
responsibilities but also for the
district as a whole and it is clearly
that we would like to in our report
refer to the fact that data is
absolutely crucial I think you wouldn't
expect anything more anything
for myself I am a scientist by
background and data is absolutely
fundamental Thank You councillor Jared I
do have one comment on recommendation
for the council should continue efforts
to deliver an increased number of
electrical electric vehicle charging
points across the district now that they
told me and Warwickshire let meet in
this morning there is absolutely no
doubt about it we do have issues with
the electricity supply into this area
it's a grid issue it's not a generation
issue there is a study going on at the
moment into the exact implications of
that and the impact of that that study
will take six months I think it will be
rather unfortunate if we started putting
in more electric charging points and
there was no electricity to actually
deliver a charge in principle very
supportive but I think we need to
understand the constraints the
electricity supply situation provides
before we actually start rolling out
electric charging points and
disappointing people
so with that recommended to cabinet six
recommendations from the task and finish
group as detailed below be adopted
include in the amended recommendation
five do I have your agreement members of
cabinet Thank You members of cabinet in
that case we move all to unblock items
and these are just for noting no
requests being made for an item to be
discussed so these are a minutes of the
housing investment panel the minutes of
the strategic policy advisory group
and the minutes of the cash management
working group so those are for noting so
moving on to Part II urgent business do
you have any urgent business it's not I
may have misunderstood the process to
get this here there were a couple of
things that came out it was specifically
about the broadband being a UK stuff I
mentioned you earlier whether I should
bring that up under Part C clearly
there's no line item on it with wrapping
up here been under Part C yeah
my apologies dude yeah yeah yeah that's
not from when I spoke to you earlier yes
and you haven't been formally notified
subs we this was done after the agenda
was published I don't know whether you
want me to do it now or if you want me
to wait until the next meeting I can
bring it to the next meeting which would
you rather it's very straightforward
raise them now okay thank you I
appreciate that so we had to be the UK
and come to our meeting last week and I
had a wider discussion overall and there
are a couple of things that the avene
scrutiny committee wanted to suggest to
the cabinet those were first of all that
we believe that council should continue
to work BT UK through the phase 3
element of their project as there is
insufficient evidence to suggest that
there are any other odd workable
alternatives at this stage but would
also ask that counselling cabinet and
continues to make best use of the
authorities gained share funding
allocation to support delivery of wider
coverage of fibre across the district
and that council should seek to lobby
government to amend planning law to
mandate that broadband services become a
formal requirement for any new build
properties we've obviously spoken to a
counselor cargill who's the port fare
holder for that and he's fully
supportive and was in fact at the
meeting and accepted those but I wanted
to bring those up with you now so that
you can either accept or choose what you
like
so we know that those points thank you
so no urgent business in that case we
move back to item six the material
recycling facility and the minute we go
into any issues that may be contained in
the exempt appendices then we exclude
the public councillor Shenton yours I
believe
Thank You Jerry the recovery report that
you have in front of you sets out the
opportunity to become a partner in the
regional recycling facility in
conjunction with nunn even embed birth
nourriture and rugby baroque and source
as well as Coventry study hall and
Warsaw Metropolitan Borough Council's
under the proposal and at the new
facility will be built next to the
energy from waste plant a country and
this would provide a state of the art
recycling find owned by the partner
councils which would be a valuable asset
and in providing and enhancing how
recycling service going fools cabinet
members will recall brief in a
reasonable Steve from the project
director for the scheme and this is
summarized in the executive summary of
the business case included in the
confidential appendix to the report it's
clear that gate fees have and will
continue to increase going forward with
both Ralph and left side of recycle
quoting that new contracts in the West
Midlands are currently being negotiated
with gate fees in excess of the 60 pound
per ton in the confidential base case
included in your papers some are in
excess of 90 pounds
excuse me counselor Shenton if you get
in into numbers like that sorry
should we that's the only number of any
questions yes I I have to say when we
get into the discussion yes I do as well
in that case can I just say that
pursuant to section 108 brackets for the
Local Government Act 1972 as amended the
public be excluded from the remaining
business of the meeting in view of the
fact that the nature of the proceedings
will be such that if the public will
present there would likely be disclosure
to them of exempt information on the
paragraph three of part one of the shed
Ewell 12a to the said act as amended
so if members of the public could leave
please be very grateful then we'll
continue with the meat